hello so for this role there was a lot
of physicality between physical labor
fighting William and a scene and then
getting into character putting your
fingers down your throat to cry no I
kind of I I did it it was just that was
something I wanted to do I basically I
did what I wanted to throw up on the
first scene and then superstition thing
him and I just Evan I became more and
more more when I was just throwing up
just pretty much before every stake but
I thought I was doing it very subtly but
then I realized I have a mic on and so I
big off in the corner I meant before
every tag I guess when they realized in
the Edit and here's right I could take
out to take up the take and it's really
how disgusting it was this role your
role in the lighthouse is getting awards
season buzz and of course you're in the
news right now so do you love it or hate
it when it comes to all the attention I
mean I barely even noticed to be honest
I mean it's kind of I mean with this
movie I'm so that's it's so hard to get
anyone to see anything and then to
remove it this was just pretty
aggressively strange and to see it's
getting any kind of notice I mean it's
like I have done so many little movies
where it's sort of fight to get anyone
to see them in a sec for stuff
yeah and when you get this one which is
like probably the strangest movie I've
ever do it's great yeah and you get to
see people not only going to see it but
like laughing and kind of and really
getting it I mean it's sort of it's yes
a pleasure how do you unwind I know
you're not on Instagram so what else are
you doing
that's the idea of what I do mind Spiros
I'm not really that tighten already that
wound up I'm pretty pretty chill out by
everything but yeah I like working I'm
in there and something like this when I
never sleep better then when you've done
to me where you're kind of waiting all
day been going mental all day on there
so it's like loved it you just go home
after a team spirit it's like I've spent
every single bit of energy I have I'm
down I'm out blackout dreamless sleep
fighting William Dafoe was it fun was it
nerve-racking what's really strong yeah
and I had very bony knuckles as well and
so we're punching each other and these
crazy bruises all over like hey pulling
your punches but it's fun I mean it I
mean some of those fight scenes it I
love working with people as well right
it's kind of I find out in choreographed
fight it's very difficult I'm quite
frustrating I can't be bothered to
remember all this stuff we're late so I
love working with an actor who say all
right let's just not like punch each
other in the face but that's kind of
rolling around on the floor and have
like have a play fight basically and
Williams very much down to kind of get
get pretty physical I love that thank
you for your time just thank you